sorry about it guys i had some technical
difficulties spent all this time trying
to get my
webcam set up and it did not work well
so i think i had a few of you waiting
i think lost you somewhere else um i
have some questions that came in from
jacob henderson from amy patrick i'll
get to those right now and then
hopefully
people start
finding me on this uh
you know hold on just second
just waiting let me see if i can pull
them over
good
so
all right all right we're here
sorry that was a mess
um
thanks for bearing with me uh as i was
saying i had all this time i spent like
an hour trying to set up my dslr camera
for my webcam so we didn't have this
like shitty grainy
resolution but
it didn't work i didn't have the right
software as a big mess and then anyways
so here we are um i have a couple of
questions i'm going to get to you i have
jacob henderson and amy patrick i'm
going to try to get to everybody's i try
to burn through them quick you guys know
me i can talk at length lose track of
time i always say i have 45 minutes i
end up going an hour and a half
um
i'm gonna start with jacob you had any
advice for those going into ems
specifically the fire service
general strength training seems to be
the best way to go with
those type of careers that have some
type of like physical
component
police fire whatever it is
it's not very rigorous you just have to
be
generally stronger than most of the
population and not be in terrible shape
so i don't think you need to specialize
if you're strength training you're
probably ahead of everybody else that's
going to do it i would just recommend
doing some type of row cardio i mean
it's not that hard just
running a couple times a week
getting an idea of what the physical
test is
if you're tested on a physical test and
it's not just the job demands
i mean carrying and picking things up is
going to be most of it so if you
deadlift and squat you're ahead of the
curve you take it one step further and
do some sandbag stuff here and there but
it's not like i mean look at the shape
most dms's are in it's not like it
requires really demanding
uh
physic uh physicality in order to do
well amy patrick can you touch on the
lead up to competition specifically when
to transition from regular training to
the peak taper phase
thanks
um
competition i'm assuming power lifting
the same principles are going to apply
with all strength sports
uh but the transition from regular
training to the peak taper phase
so
the basic principle is that everything
starts very broad everything starts very
non-specific so most of your training is
going to be things that you generally
think will get you stronger
and then as you get closer to the meat
i mean the tapers the last couple of
weeks but we should be in a strength or
competition specific phase
a month or six weeks before then so
eight weeks of specific training 12 even
i mean if i'm doing a strong man meet
and i know the con the events and it's a
big event i'm going to be doing event
specific work
probably about 10 weeks out so that's
six to eight weeks of very specific
heavy training for the event followed by
a couple weeks to taper which includes a
deload so
heavy stuff at some point you're
building up to a certain amount of
volume with the heavier threshold if
it's powerlifting it's a certain amount
of volume at 90 and up dealing with
those slower reps learning how to grind
getting the technique dialed in
and then
eventually uh
the taper is where all of that volume
drops off so
a newer lifter it might be a week a
newer lifter can do a heavy ass workout
five days out three days out even an
intermediate is going to need at least a
week of solid recovery very advanced
lifters will need two sometimes three
weeks so you'll see guys that have 800
pound squats or we're up
and if they're you know over here
they're let's say four weeks out they'll
work up they'll take their heaviest
attempt
and then every week is lowering the
intensity and lowering the volume
they're still working but they're
peeling it back a little bit and as they
do that their performance is climbing up
so the transition
i think just means peeling away work
that doesn't matter and allowing
yourself to recover for strongman uh
what we'll generally do because it's
rarely max i mean we do max but it's
usually on an odd implement or a or for
rep so the the exact peak doesn't matter
quite as much you have to
uh you have to have a touch a little bit
closer even if you're advanced so for
someone like me i mean my overhead my
deadlift is is
close to advanced um
i'll go like two weeks out about 14 days
my last heavy touch and then i'll spend
the rest of the time doing conditioning
stuff which you have to do closer to the
meat and then i'll peel away all of the
um heavy volume stuff or the static
events in that time but if i have a
heavy log for reps i have to do that the
week of or i'll lose conditioning
so the last uh heavy day's about 14 days
out the next event day is like an 80 day
and then we have a full delos going into
the into the meat so it's just a matter
of building up contest specific volume
pushing it pushing and pushing it right
to where you start to feel like [__] and
then knowing exactly how much time you
need in order to peel away all that work
so that you recover in an adequate
timeline
so we're just getting started already
went too long um
swoll invictus literally stuck on a farm
in nowhere until august trying to
maintain size and strength with
gymnastic rings and stone lifts there's
worse equipment to have
how well do you think stone carries
suited to maintain a deadlift uh better
than dead lifting for many people it's
very hard to overtrain it's going to
beat you down but it doesn't have the
same cns fatigue
that kind of hits the human body in the
way that it's supposed to be used those
muscles bracing and supporting while you
work so stone carries are fantastic if
you take them seriously you can get your
upper back even maybe your arms a little
thickened out
your capacity will be huge erectors and
hamstrings have to deal with uh
deal with much more
time under tension than they otherwise
would anywhere in the gym stone carries
are fantastic do them a couple times a
week if you have multiple stones you can
do
heavy sprints one day you could work on
footwork and speed the other day you can
do endurance just long i mean like two
and three hundred foot carries if
anybody has the balls to do that that is
a fantastic training tool i noticed that
every time i have to do a husqvail stone
my last tesol carry was over 300 pounds
and it went right around 300 feet
um pick up a 150 stone try to carry it
300 feet
take the groceries
300 feet and see how fatigued you are it
is a great cross training tool carries
over fantastically well to the deadlift
in fact make it a mission
stones and gymnastic rings do what you
can with them over a couple of months
and report back because if you do it
right you should come back in pretty
good shape don't slack off on it those
are pretty good tools to maintain
general ability
i have some greetings hello hey how are
you
hey everybody thank you for joining us
figured it out i know me too
thoughts on fluff and pump work also
adding more exercises equals less sets
on a body part and more sets equals less
exercises what are your thoughts so
fluff and pump work absolutely
i mean is it mandatory no i tend to
think that the people that have the most
specific training whereas they're just
doing let's say the olympic lifts or
they're just doing the strong man events
or they're just doing the power lifts
there are less dials to turn which can
paint you into a corner more that means
your training has to be more monotonous
and you have to really fine-tune the
dials because you're training so
specifically all the time i think most
people are best off training in kind of
a wide what you might think of just
bodybuilding training just with your
main lift being present on some type of
progression i think that works best for
uh for just about everybody
um
i didn't do a mic test can anybody
comment is my mic on right now
i've done this before where i've talked
for like an hour and none of it was
usable
yes fritz it's on perfect thanks guys i
just got paranoid i've done that more
times than i can count um
all right so getting back to it uh fluff
and pump work it's valuable
it's good for building muscle especially
in smaller areas everybody eventually
will develop a weakness but the best way
to fix weaknesses is to prevent them in
the first place so if you have a rote
amount of well-rounded bodybuilding type
training you can keep your lats or your
rear delts or your biceps or your
hamstrings from becoming weak links uh
it's also easy to recover from it's also
good for getting blood into the joints
and actually getting restorative work in
it's better for capacity it burns more
calories so it's easier to stay lean
there's so many good things to doing
smaller amounts of work that
it's silly not to and it gives you more
tools in your in your tool chest
it shouldn't be all the time if you're
gearing up for a meet that's the first
stuff to go so if i'm six weeks out from
a meet or if i'm leading into a test
that's the first thing to go
but assuming i'm just doing general
generic training absolutely i'm gonna
keep the fluff work in um
getting back to the question of uh
adding more exercise equals less sets on
a body part and more
more sets equals less exercises what are
your thoughts
um
i'm trying to think
more sets equals
less exercises
so you're going to do
i mean yeah if you're only squatting
obviously you're going to do a lot more
sets of squats than you would if you
were squatting doing good mornings and
leg presses but there is a pretty wide
spectrum of volume you can potentially
be doing
with effort it's a lot more important so
very very high effort
that means
uh less total sets because you go really
hard to hit this high top set
fatigue catches up so fast that this is
what subsequent sets look like whereas
if you uh find this cruising altitude
and just kind of hang out you can keep
that area under that curve represents
more total work so volume is going to be
highest if you keep effort down and go
longer but as far as the number of sets
i mean
it depends how conditioned you are it
depends how quickly you ramp up to it it
depends how specifically you're training
it depends what your motor progression
is so i know very effective power
lifters who
only do a few sets a week and maybe some
fluff work and if they're really pushing
the envelope on their few lifts they
might be able to do a lot of exercises
with high intensity
and similarly i know guys that um
train with very high frequency and do
everything under the sun it really
depends on what you're adapted to um
your body will tell you you're always on
the hook for getting the right answer
the right answer means that you went
through a phase of training didn't run
yourself into the ground and actually
got a little bit better at the end of it
so if you can chart progress week to
week and you're not falling apart
congratulations you got the right answer
there's different ways to bleed into
different types of training so you don't
want to just jump into you know throwing
everything at your lift
including the kitchen sink so radical
stuff you have to work up to build a
tolerance to but there's so many ways to
prescribe volume over how many sets of
exercise you choose
omni touch
bb just started compound lifts my bench
is stuck very low and i believe it to be
half
form and half needing to build the base
muscles to be able to lift 155 more than
one time since i weighed 275 tips i got
feels for that man
155 that weight is burned into my brain
my first year playing football i was 13
i was in high school i was actually a
sophomore i started high school early so
i was trying to sneak in and fit in with
the bigger kids i don't even think i had
hit puberty yet
at 13 i think i did i hadn't really hit
my growth spurt yet
no no i was 5 10. i've been 5 10 since i
was 12. i never grew another inch
that was really depressing that was one
of the most heartbreaking twists in my
life i thought i was gonna be like six
foot four so
anyways i was 13 i was in football and
i'd never lifted that was my first
introduction to physical activity 155
was the test weight and i remember
going in psyching up and trying to
bounce it off my chest and failing on a
155 bench i was 5 10 probably 180 pounds
and i was just weak as a kitten and i
was kind of soft i was chunky up until
i've been lifting for a couple of years
i'm still a little chunky
so i see 155 on a bench and i'm just
like
but that was one of the biggest
experiences i had with conquering that
weight when i trained for a couple of
months came back and i was at 185 for a
few then 205 for a few then 225 for a
few and it kept snowballing so
you just started your new year heavy so
it's not like you're a hard gainer
you're under feeding you just need
experience
technique is something you always build
on always focus on building up technique
don't
for years you don't need to worry about
technique as being the limiting factor i
mean if you're all over the place that's
one thing fix it but don't think about
trying to technique your way especially
in a bench press a bench pretty
one-dimensional all you need to do
is do an appropriate amount of work be
consistent
build up week to week to week and stick
to the progression if you feel yourself
yourself starting to get spread thin
that just means you have to back up a
little bit and start again it's just an
ebb and flow three four weeks moving
forward back up start again back up
start again that's all it is so the best
thing you can do find the program
absolutely stick to it be realistic
about the numbers you pick
at your level you could probably do
starting strength i'd recommend like
grayscale up here or 531 or kind of my
go-tos for people who are brand brand
new but don't think that you're gonna
bench five days a week and get a better
don't think you're going to technique
your way into more strength it's work
just keep in mind people accidentally
get 300 pound benches by virtue of of
having labor jobs or engaging in other
sports
it's there the if the working
consistency isn't there it doesn't
matter and the working consistency by
itself will get you well beyond that 155
bench don't don't even worry about it
just stick to it um advice for longer
limb lifter as far as pressing goes more
pressing that's it and that doesn't mean
go and like
try to press your balls off and
constantly hit one rep maxes that means
that means that you are consistently
getting good quality touches in good
quality work
being disadvantaged probably means
you're not going to recover quite as
well
if you're not a very well developed
presser i would guess but don't think
too much about that
i would just have a lot of sets of a
couple of compound movements that put
you through a pretty uh pretty full
range of motion i mean you have long
limbs and um
don't be afraid to do things that short
stroke the motion as well
that's something talking about uh with
alpha destiny that kind of clicked it
kind of made sense is generally you can
go a lot harder in a lift if you are in
the pocket if you're in the sweet spot
of motion so
if you're uh what if you're a more
advantaged lifter you have a shorter
range of motion you can go harder if
you're really disadvantaged eats up your
recovery it's harder to go with more
volume or frequency so what you can do
is utilize variations that maybe don't
have you go down to your chest all the
time or maybe you know bodybuilders
would like call them x-reps or whatever
you think those like little short
pulsing motions get a lot of volume in
in the in the pocket
maybe not all your reps but certainly on
some of your accessories let's say if
you incline dumbbell try getting in some
heavy work without going all the way
down without locking out
that's very productive but as much you
should be aiming to get a wide variety
of reps over a lot of sets with a lot of
pressing exercises
i would specifically say to reduced rpe
because being disadvantaged a high rp is
going to screw with your recovery a bit
more so that's my generic advice
um
intermediate lifter doing upper lower
split and just come back from a knee
injury so upper lifts are quite ahead
uh how would i
how can i program squats and deadlifts
on a weekly basis to improve
that's too open-ended a question to
answer anything if you're if you're
behind anything is gonna work
don't jump into it a hundred percent
just
do anything and stick to it i would
actually recommend no
little to no frequency well
some frequency once a week i would
recommend once a week run through a
squat variation and deadlift variation
some isolation movements
and uh that's it that's how i came back
from my leg break i broke my leg my
ankle completely off my leg and i still
have a plate in there that kind of
screws with me
makes yolk walks really fun
i feel the
screws scraping around as i'm taking
steps with 900 pounds
but coming back i just went on a simple
linear progression it comes back so so
so fast so don't try to jump into it
start very light
once a week every time just little jumps
you're never trying to go to 100 for
that day you got to build out a base
first and levy to it before you can hit
that cruising altitude but the type of
program you're on doesn't matter my
recommendations start light and easy
progress linearly once you feel like
you're back to your old self then uh
then you can go on any program you like
it's a matter of sticking to it not
hopping around
how would you prep for strength meats
that are a few weeks apart so if there
is enough time to peak how would you
structure it
oh for arm wrestling i couldn't tell you
that's an entirely different sport i
know i say principles apply to
everything and they do but there's
specifics there um for general strength
training i wouldn't you have to accept
that one of them you're not going to be
and that's okay if you're doing it for
experience that's fine and if you're
doing it um some guys are really really
good and get away with it tyler young
did
what did he do america's strongest man
last year i competed against him and
then two weeks later he went into
nationals he was pissed at how he did at
asm so he went to nationals with a chip
on the shoulder he got his pro card i
would have told him right off the bat
dude you're gonna eat [__] like why
would you do that you're not going to do
well
and
he ended up killing it i think he took a
second got his pro card it's fantastic
for him thing is tyler's really good so
even tyler not peaked and recovered can
still do that well but if you don't have
time to actually peak you just have to
accept you're not going to do as well as
you could um usually you take a deload
after a contest anyways to clear out
um i would do the contest reduce
training for a week next week get kind
of
rpe seven to eight like little to medium
volume pretty contest specific and then
hopefully you have a week after to dial
that down again as you recover but you
know who knows for arm wrestling i don't
know because you have to deal with
inflammation probably depends on how
beat up your arm is old pros can
probably do it new guys are probably
going to be in a lot of pain i don't
know just don't break your arm
should we avoid squatting
the deadlift on a max lift or is it okay
to rely on legs for just getting that pr
squatting i mean that's a technical
thing uh adnan
you can absolutely use your legs on a
deadlift man if you're stronger
squatting into it squat into it
some lifters squat into it some have
their hips high that's personal
preference doesn't invalidate the lift
um just make sure that you're squatting
it uh
i mean i can imagine all the ways that
that goes wrong
where a completely new lifter tries to
squat the weight and the bar is trying
to like round out over the kneecaps but
if you're efficient strong that way go
for it
what's your suggestion structuring power
building for strong man at a commercial
gym that's how i did strong man for the
first couple of years i worked out at a
24-hour fitness i had
like an axle and that was it it was a
galvanized piece of pipe from home depot
that was 20 bucks
um
general strength training
general bodybuilding carries it sets you
up nicely for just about everything so
your heavy lifts
if you're dead lifting squatting
pressing that carries over to just about
everything the more rowing you do the
better time you're going to have with
things that require strong upper back
which is everything
um
working into deep rep ranges higher up
squatting high rep deadlifting will help
you out
uh if you don't have access to equipment
it is what it is there's no set of
movements that are going to perfectly
set you up for it you can just get your
physical boxes checked which goes a long
way when you're new when you're in a
novice or just starting on the open
class just being strong in condition
goes a long way so just focus on those
um power building it's it's like you
have your main it's the same as
everything you have your main compound
lifts you have your variations and then
you have a run of bodybuilding movements
that's about it um
have you ever trained non-strength sport
athlete amateur yes i have i've trained
a lot of sedentary people a lot of
middle-aged accountants
a lot of teenage gamers
nothing's different for for people that
don't love training for two hours that's
where you go to like a just simple
linear progression treat the lifts as a
skill
repeat them over and over progress
linearly that's great for most people
what strategies do i use to train around
pain and injury
um
that's such a wide umbrella such a wide
umbrella i have to cast it depends what
i think it is but i can never accurately
predict what it is i feel like i can
predict what it is at this point in my
career better than a specialist can
especially where they where it tends to
pop up it's one thing when you like blow
your knee out or you blow your shoulder
out you can go get a diagnosis they'll
tell you
it happened to richie moxie gemba he
went to clash he's a fantastic athlete
he podiumed last year i thought he was
now that can be dropped out i thought he
was in the running to win it first event
of the finals circus dumbbell 210 pound
one arm dumbbell press uh as i
understand it uh separated as ac joint
and i think it took a lot of tendons and
connective tissue with it
that's diagnosable you know what that is
you know something mechanically has to
repair and there's an order of
operations
low back like random hip pain random
knee pain stuff that seems to like set
in and linger and then go away
it's a lot harder i'm always i never
work in a pain as a rule and i know
there's this whole school of thought
that things that oh you're you're
engaging in no deception
i think that's [__] stupid i've made
that clear
i follow what the successful people do
both in the middle competitive ranks and
the highest competitive ranks and i
don't know a single person who's made a
habit of working into pain they exist by
the way
the people that work into pain exist
there's a lot of them
they're all [__] up nobody has gotten
better nobody said yeah i i popped a
couple of vicodin and got through that
next meet or i just you know kind of put
my head down and went through it there's
i'm sure there's some middle ground
between putting your head down and going
through it and not doing anything at all
few people
end up nicely in that middle ground my
approach is always fine things i can do
never stay inactive that's one i can
always find things i can do doing
nothing is probably the worst thing you
can do
short of
you know loading up a bunch of weight
and saying [__] it and doing a yolo lift
uh i always find something i can do
and i make sure that
it doesn't seem to be making the issue
worse
and that's very subjective
it's hard to guess and it is guessing
the more
the more time you do it the better
handle you have on it i spent 10 years
in chronic pain and injury that limited
my strength gains made day-to-day life
miserable made it hard to do very basic
[__] there were multiple times where i
thought i was having a comeback and then
i was in pain and i'm like
i can't keep doing this i just i can't
keep doing it and i know a lot of
competitors
i mean if you're competing it's bad
enough but if you're not even
competitive
like why live your life like that so
i've had that come to jesus moment so
many times where i just thought i wasn't
gonna lift anymore i'm like [__] it's
not worth it and then finally i found
what it was i got my [__] straightened
out i changed my approach and it all
involves being realistic about what i
can handle that day being very very uh
strict on my technical execution and not
just saying [__] it it'll be fine
because it's never fine once you get to
a certain level of strength and you get
some miles on you it's just not
and i was uh deliberate about my pacing
and my approaching and not trying to
consistently use heavier weights to
drive progress instead train let the
strength come as a byproduct of good
solid execution and that was a game
changer for me it was my midsection
that's why i pushed bracing so much i
had a stomach that was made of pudding
uh my back
hurt constantly i had a dozen injuries
over 10 years and i thought oh i just
got to get back in i'll get stronger
i'll adapt and it never happened that
way so not all the times very often
there's one thing you can pinpoint and
it's hard to pinpoint it if you're
always living in pain so i know there's
not a lot of substance in that to pull
out that's kind of the broad principle
cast a wide blanket
uh try to try to encompass as much as
you can without reducing your training
to zero that's it and guys i got a lot
of questions um
if any of you have a pressing question
that you want to prioritize because i'm
just going down the list i do respond to
super chats first i do respond to
members first uh jacob jacob henderson's
og member i think he was the first
member i had so he was the first one to
comment so i was always give jacob
attention first um
going down the list
i lost my place
video of clarence kennedy squat jerking
a log
i haven't but clarence kennedy's a freak
and there's no doubt in my mind that he
could squat jerk a heavy log do you
think the squad jerk could be viable
technique for a lot of clean depressing
short answer is no i had this discussion
with uh sheather who's getting ready for
a log press and was talking about the
viability of the jerk
viability of a jerk
exists
almost entirely with people who have a
deep olympic lifting background the
technical barrier is hard to
to uh overcome
so if you haven't started with it and
you've already gotten stronger and
gotten a handle on some of the events
and some of the movement patterns you're
not going to get it just most people
aren't going to get it people will get
away with a shitty split jerk
you'll see someone like kearney does a
shitty split jerk i mean it's effective
it gives them enough of an edge but it's
probably not that much higher than he
would push jerk or push press which
tells you he's technically not a good
jerker because if you're good at the
jerk you're gonna have all this real
estate uh in between those lifts
um well tyler young does it
but again it's not that much higher than
what he can push press or push her
it's so specialized takes so much effort
away from general pressing power work
and it's so technical has to be kept up
on if you want to be sharp and if it
doesn't give you that much of a return
also you can't you can't do it with a
dumbbell you can't do it with a keg
can't do it with all the other things
you would press so it becomes less and
less viable given the amount of time
that you have to spend towards it i use
terry rady as an example
say what you will about the guy he's
[__] bananas but he's a very very
good athlete he is very physically
gifted he's
not been competing in strongman very
much
super skinny right now i think
but his uh he's been doing a lot of
olympic lifting work
i think he had a 400 pound log at one
point as a 105 that's with a push press
his split jerk sucks and he's been doing
it
pretty consistently for a couple of
years so anyways big technical
uh
hill to climb so if you're not already
camby did a lot of olympic lifting work
he worked with the russian coach i
believe for a while so camby has that in
his back pocket for most strong men not
worth the time and effort um what
kokolaev is a good example of a guy who
came a russian weightlifting champion
had a 550 clean and jerk
couldn't hang with z on the press
because whatever advantage you get over
here
eventually gets nullified by the other
traits you need which is stability
familiarity with the equipment and just
really strong [__] lockout so
you know you get something you lose
something
uh shoulder pain on a horizontal push
i can't diagnose stuff i'd paint with
such a broad umbrella could be
tendonitis
um
pain with a broad brush again don't
train into pain
if it gets worse and worse and worse you
might have to give it a break uh try to
incorporate while you give it a break
from the heavy stuff try to incorporate
stuff that gets blood flow in
um
i like to do stuff with the voodoo floss
band where you wrap it around the
painful tendon and force motion back and
forth and then after two or three
minutes and put a timer on it you take
it off blood dumps in feels a lot better
general banded work helps for very very
high reps
but it's a balance how much is that
stuff going to help versus how much you
have to reduce the thing that's causing
the pain to linger it's not an easy
answer
unfortunately
um any advice for people going into
firefighting like how to arrange workout
to cycles i answered that in the
beginning uh jacob after this is
published you can go back and look at
that um
general strength training be in
generally good shape that's about it
it's not very specialized it doesn't
have a high barrier
um how do i treat lower back pain during
a workout a lot of pain questions
uh lower back hurts during higher volume
deadlifts and squats to a lesser extent
i always look at what your spine is
doing first because it's one of the
things that most people don't pay
attention to and it's one of the things
that's easiest most easily fixed so it's
not that that's all of it it's not that
that's all of the things that you're
going to be
that's not the root of all of the pain
that you're going to experience but it's
that it pops up frequently enough enough
people don't pay attention to it and
it's easily fixed it's like okay let's
start there so
it's very common for people when they're
doing a hip hinge to move at the spine
so look at yourself in the mirror take
video have somebody watch you
stand up like you're gonna do an rdl
this is your hip and as you hinge
see if there's any movement in your
lumbar spine or see if okay i'm fine i'm
fine i'm fine but right here i'm
inflexible and i have to round a little
bit to get down same thing can happen in
a squat
with squatting i find that um
elevating your heel fixes it for a lot
of people and you can do that
organically you get the same effect just
by getting more ankle mobility
stretching your uh
stretching your calf out getting your
ankle loose but just
two and a half pound plates or a thin
board if you don't have you don't don't
have to go buy olympic lifting shoes
elevate the heel try to stay upright and
brace it's what the abs do they keep the
spine in place so if you find that
activating squeezing like about to get
punched in the stomach if you find that
you can get to the bottom and things are
more flush
then you're going to be avoiding
movement whatever that tender area is
but you're also going to be avoiding hip
uh
glue pumps and back pumps which i've
gotten before which made it very hard to
operate um
focus on your bracing first and don't
play into pain that's it don't think oh
i'm just gonna get better because you
know maybe you will but if you won't
that's gonna be a big problem so
evaluate evaluate technique front squats
tend to be easier than back squats to
maintain posture i recommend learning
how to do really good rdls uh
before you you start doing a lot of
deadlifts and just brace brace brace
brace
your uh stomach strength and your
receptivity how you sense and are aware
of your abs and your bracing that is
just as if not more important than what
your lower back is doing
yeah if pain's gone the next day then um
it's generally just inflammation
so many of you
what are your thoughts on training soar
dr mike says it's a huge no-no
another patreon og
atlantic canoe
uh well if dr mike says it then you
shouldn't do it
uh
depends how sore you are it depends what
the context is i've trained sore
multiple times but
that's in the context of already being
pretty well conditioned
and decently strong and in good shape
like
i'm not gonna
in desperation to get my tiny triceps
built up i've gone in and done like six
exercises five sets each and the next
day my arm is like puffy and swollen and
i can barely straighten it out and it
hurts to the touch i would not go in and
do triceps again after that so if it's
sore because of like severe
tissue breakdown and there's this
inflammation response yeah i would say
no but i've been sore from an exercise
i'm not really used to or if i'm doing a
little extra volume on a compound lift
where i kind of feel it the next day and
if i'm a little sore and i'm
due to press
i'll go press like i'm not going to
avoid it but that's different than the
the really debilitating doms that you
might get if it's
if you're wincing to take a [__] don't
go squat you know if you're having a
hard time just getting through the day
don't go lift but if it's just like
residual soreness it's not a big deal
and the muscles get conditioned so
stupidly fast muscles get conditioned so
incredibly fast to really high frequency
and really high volume so
assuming your joints can hang with it
as you train more frequently you're
going to find that you don't even really
get sore anymore
the soreness is really just evidence
that it's a new movement or that you did
an exceptional amount of work but the
point is to adapt to that amount of work
how effective is banded calisthenics for
hypo for hypertrophy
um better than not doing anything
i have no information to go off of so i
don't know what the most jacked cow is i
mean just doing bodyweight stuff you can
add muscle you can always find ways to
make it harder banded stuff increases
tension so
i would say pretty good i mean
calisthenics up by itself can be pretty
good if you're disciplined if you're
dedicated if you
stay with it you don't just do it every
now and then and expect that you're like
gonna be doing one-arm pull-ups but it's
a it's a way of loading a compound
movement so i would think pretty
effective probably not as effective as
having access to a full gym but
don't let perfect be the enemy of good
uh
thoughts on protracting the shoulders
when benching protracting i mean letting
him forward letting him out i had a
discussion with alex from alpha destiny
about this i thought i was a trailblazer
when i was trying to get my shitty bench
up and i realized that my delts were
overbuilt
they were overbuilt don't look at them
right now but uh my pecs have never been
big and when they were a little filled
out when i was doing extra peck work my
bench just felt amazing off the bottom
position
um
pain in my shoulders was generally
reduced so i was always trying to think
okay how do i get my chest more
developed because i'm doing this very
tight specialized little five inch range
of motion bench and things are still
hurting my physique's not really
changing
and i started
relaxing my shoulders out i started
going a little bit wider relaxing my
shoulders and honestly kind of work in
the mid-range and i do really high reps
get a sick pump sick burn in my chest
and uh over time my chest grew very
easily and because i was using kind of
reduced weights it didn't cause a lot of
shoulder issues
which was strange so i thought i was
brilliant and then i found that he was
doing the exact same thing
and it makes sense you disadvantage
yourself for a lift now would i
recommend somebody go out and go balls
out and really strain and grind with
their shoulders in that kind of shitty
loose position no but look we do stiff
legged deadlifts we do ask to grasp
pause squats uh we do all kinds of
things that put us a precarious position
so
i think it's fine as long as you're you
know your limits and you're paying
attention to what your response to that
movement is i mean the name of the game
is to disadvantage you now you know
what's going to happen if you get
reckless your pec insertion is going to
hurt
you know that uh you might develop
shoulder issues you might pop something
bicep injury that's the default uh
strongman injury you're not a strong man
till you pop your bicep well you're not
a power lifter until you pop something
in your shoulder and i've popped things
in my shoulder a few times it's not fun
you want to avoid that so the more
stupid you get in that position the more
likely something's going to go but i
think it is a tool
um do you think having spd days for
power lifters is needed in me prep i
never had them in training before but i
feel like i should any thoughts no i
honestly don't think so
i can imagine a particular person who is
very powerful and maybe in shitty shape
where the day actually does get to them
but my training i
deadlift after i squat routinely and for
volume so if anything the time spent
benching
100 if that's not recovery for you for
your deadlift you're in [__] horrible
shape
if you benching fatigues you for the
deadlift you are just saying god awful
shape your training sucks so adding that
unnecessary element of specificity to
get around being in really shitty shape
i find
i find that unnecessary
i routinely have people do this as well
and they complain so much having people
squat then dead lift maybe squatting
again that's something i pulled from
shaco
but usually you're squatting and doing
hips hip hinge stuff in the same workout
and if you're doing it for repeating
sets for a lot of volume with a lot of
effort
you're gonna be conditioned to doing a
couple of singles in each lift like five
hours apart so um
i don't think so just make sure that
you're working hard enough in your
training that you're not being lazy
uh amateur strongman 100 kilos never
competed but have been watching the 105s
and clash on the coast besides a few
most are enhanced in the top level
that is true
i would say all are it's not a secret
in the gear thing i tried not to talk
about too much because i didn't want
that to be the theme what we talk about
training what you guys have to
understand
pretty universal if you're talking about
training principles recovery is like the
biggest thing that that matters
and
all of the ways
like good programming training is going
to talk about how to assess your own
recovery abilities so that's universal
the thing that gear does it
you recover a lot faster but also your
joints tear down a little bit more but
you get a lot more sooner and that can
create its own problems but you're still
on the hook for figuring out what that
pacing is so you can say a lot of the
guys can get away with stuff that might
be true but no matter who you are i mean
you can be natty and have the absolute
best genetics and get away with a whole
bunch of [__] other people can't you are
always on the hook for figuring out what
works for you so the discussion around
programming is largely the same
but it's something that
as it seems like there's a lot of people
talking about it there's a natty guys
that are always talking about it because
that's their brand
some ways that can kind of be their cope
but i get it you need your own in a sea
of juice monkeys you need your own space
rubish is doing a lot of cool [__]
getting people to talk openly about gear
and i think it's an important
conversation we have as long as it
doesn't go to this
typically toxic place people are going
to do what they're going to do and you
feeling it's unfair or whatever kind of
way you feel about it it's not going to
change it
it's up to you to control the things you
can control and make sure you can do the
best and 99.9 of people
have no idea what they're capable of
doing without and to somebody who
trained very long without any substances
i can attest that paying attention
working very hard having unreasonably
high standards for yourself can take all
of you so much farther than you probably
thought you were capable of going with
or without gear anyways but it's the one
um
thing that most people don't know if
you're either on one side of the fence
and you're aware that like literally
everybody is on
like everybody
and i'm not exaggerating like everybody
like
virtually 100
or you're on the other side and you're
not really exposed to it you have no
reason to think that so you tend to kind
of protect and preserve your favorite
lifters and maybe think well no not them
because you've assigned some morality to
in your head you don't accept that the
guy you like is doing this thing but i
can't emphasize enough how absolutely
normalized it is that doesn't mean you
should do it in fact i feel like most
people shouldn't do it because there is
risk and there is stuff that you have to
figure out for yourself just like if i
was a rock climber
and i was free soloing these steep ass
cliffs
where there's like a high chance of
death if anything goes wrong
you know i can say rules for me or sorry
i got that backwards i can say rules for
the he and not for me because i'm
experienced and i've evaluated the risk
and i understand what i'm trying to do
and i've made a very sincere discussion
you know if all the guys at the bottom
wagged their finger and said well you
know uh had like why why would you say
that other people can't do it it's fine
for you you're still promoting it so i
see it as the same type of risk
people are going to make that decision
but that's a long roundabout way of
saying like yes if you want to compete
the upper echelon of competition
requires doing this thing that you might
not want to do and it's fine not
everybody is entitled to compete
especially the way that they want to
compete so that's it that's sorry that's
my two cents on that um it's an
interesting conversation but i don't
want the channel to be dominated by gear
talk so i avoid it quite a bit
okay i'm finally down to all my mic
checks thanks guys
dealing with a hip imbalance that
affects my whole body any exercises
honestly i don't have a lot of good
stuff uh for dealing with that type of
thing
one you want to make sure that
your hip shift is substantial and it's
not just something you're fixating on
that doesn't really mean anything
everybody's asymmetrical i take a
picture of myself at the bottom of a
squat i'm extremely asymmetrical um i
believe there are situations where that
asymmetry can be the cause of other
problems and when you start to deal with
chronic issues you want to find that one
thing so you'll try to correct
everything and i don't necessarily think
that's wrong but
it also doesn't mean that the symmetries
you see are necessarily going to lead
you to that path so one make sure it's
something that needs to be corrected and
it's not just a little bit of ocd
two if you are going to go through uh
correcting it just look at some good
sources out there there's some exercise
you can incorporate general awareness
goes a long way just treating the main
list is the thing that reinforces good
movement patterns but i mean you can
look at squat you uh i got his book uh
rebuilding milo's really good it was
really thorough i think it was well
worth the money considering all the
issues i had it's great for
troubleshooting
generally compound movements look in the
mirror see what your feet are doing you
know most people will feel even and like
their feet are like this you know one's
cocked way off most people will feel
even and everything's kind of torqued or
off center so that's the best way to
evaluate
long stretches just sitting into a squat
you know you do like a five minute squat
thing where you just hold on to a post
and squat down astra grass and just hold
it look in the mirror make sure you're
balanced little things like that go a
long way
excuse me it's certainly not
straightforward
um sometimes you have to get creative
considering switching overhead press for
z press my next time we base stability
is a big issue for me right now do you
recommend it i personally hate the z
press i hate it it's gimmicky it was a
big thing for a while i
god i was at strength built i saw jordan
pellick having somebody do it who was
new and i saw it i was like
that's a personal bias i have it's not
that it's useless but it's something
that looks
specific that's not that's why i don't
like it so then i go into joel seidman
territory how specific is this really
how much is this going to set you up for
the other stuff you have to get good at
strong man you're pressing on your own
two feet you're not sitting down so
balance while you're standing up
especially when you're jumping jerking
being explosive
night and day from when you're sitting
with your legs in front of you so i
don't know i haven't thought it through
to know what actual mechanical
things are adapting or changing when
your legs are out you're trying to keep
your hip flexors tight to keep from you
know falling back and dumping the bar
forward
i don't
i don't know what it's supposed to do it
is it's harder it's a little more
awkward
but for the life of me i can't attach it
to a lift that i think it inherently
makes better
than just training that lift
wouldn't do as well or better so
if you're in strong man you're pressing
seated presses should be reserved for
going really really heavy because now
it's force production because you're
stable the most specific thing you can
do is press standing and if you're
having balance issues um
better things for balance honestly more
weight in a lockout position so balances
where you start with the the pins up the
bars right here you drop under it lock
your elbows and then stand up count five
mississippis
you'll be surprised the weight you think
is fine you'll be you'll be doing this a
couple seconds in um awkward stuff like
logs i'll have people pause
so you have the setup with the log you
come down pause
and then pop into it in the quarter
squat position
you have to find why you're unstable is
it physically supporting the weight
because it's awkward is it because your
elbow isn't high or isn't locked in
you're not building tension through your
bicep and your elbow um is it you're not
just aware of your midsection maybe your
midsection sucks and you just have to
get a little stronger a lot of it can be
solved just through rope coordination so
doing the main lift i find to be the
best thing to solve that
jonathan hernandez how do i increase my
bench and press while gaining a good
amount of tissue
i'm on my third week of your high
frequency bench right now
good luck man
even that i mean i know i sold it as a
bench program the first like three
paragraphs you're saying why you
shouldn't do it uh if you live through
it you should have a nice pr most of the
guys at my gym that gave it a run on
week five they hit 20 or 30 pound pr's
not bad for five weeks um
how do i increase my bench of press
while getting a good amount of tissue
that's training it blows my mind that
these are the questions that people are
asking now and it speaks about what's
wrong with training
any point in training history they are
one in the same you do a lot of benching
you do a lot of volume you do a lot of
practice you know what happens your
upper body gets really [__] big you
get a lot of tissue that goes through
your chest your shoulders even if you're
just strength training you still gain
tissue from that it's only when you're
very very very advanced that you you
have to or this specialization will
cause you to lose a little bit of mass
or that gaining a lot of mass will cause
you to lose a little bit of strength 98
of people don't have to worry about that
and even the high volume high rep stuff
is not strength specific you still get
stronger doing it so
just good training man good training
just be consistent take notes um
get in a groove
and put the work in that's it there it's
one in the same they're the same answer
uh
a lot of questions from
all right gurpreet singh
you're lucky i'm not fast enough to know
how to block you on the spot
um
the fact you just spammed me with 15
questions not a good way to get your
question answered liam kilroy how would
you go about tracking progress
keep a notebook that's it you should be
writing every program uh every every bit
of your program down
you should be
writing your workouts planning them
ahead ideally
i think there's a thing i'm going to
branch into because i've talked so much
about deliberate programming
i think
there's a need for
programming for people that just enjoy
training and they kind of go in and do
work in an unstructured way that doesn't
really require mapping out four or six
week blocks ahead of time
i think you need to have a sense of what
you're going to do next time but
i've thought about that a lot because
some of my best years training
especially younger were very
unstructured
and it expo there was so much good stuff
came out of it i mean it led to the same
pitfalls because
not having structure meant i didn't
really know how to solve problems when
they popped up
but the value of doing a lot of
different things
was
immense
and i know for a fact i would not have
and i'm not a quick rise to the
competitive ranks but i know for a fact
i would not have been as prepared to
compete if it wasn't for the years of
unstructured work where i just enjoyed
training so and that's kind of an aside
i thought about
doing something like that for
for the person who uh doesn't find
programs sexy or appealing but still
likes to train because i think that can
be productive and even educational you i
think it can be useful but
even if you're not programming even if
you're not writing things down following
sorry even if you're not planning ahead
and following a template you should be
writing things down because there will
be a time where you experience this big
growth and you're going to want to go
back and be like well what was going on
that led to that sudden 30 pound jump in
my squat or whatever it might be um
simple notebook i have i have a fetish
for buying notebooks i have like
dozens of these with like clipboards
just around my desk most of them are
half full and scattered the little 50
cent composition pads
i i have them everywhere i have to write
things down and my brain doesn't work
uh videos on step loading are great i
like to switch back and forth between
density type
uh training and step loading for my
assistant's work that's great variation
for the sake of it keeps it interesting
prevents diminished returns so many of
these things work there's no reason why
you can't kind of experiment and
incorporate them at different times uh
as long as you've kind of stuck with it
enough to see some type of tangible
return
us here thank you
bro don't spam
um
how would you treat and prevent quad
tendinitis could it be pushing too many
accessories
uh
yeah if you're doing too much work it
could be it could be the type of
movement
it's pain in the ass because everybody's
different
certain lifts that's that are somebody's
kryptonite could be
just fine for another person they can do
them all day every day it very much is
different
um
i've had quad tendonitis a couple times
i've had it for a couple months and then
it annoyingly kind of goes away over a
couple months then it's fine the big one
was caught it's like four years ago now
i did a push jerk after not push jerking
for a while and i was about as big as
i've been i was 275 280 shoulders were
as big as they've ever been
sick bloat going on and i was bound i
was kind of tight so i had a hard time
getting my head through it that's at the
top i'd been doing a ton of push presses
my push pressing was super strong
i decided to test my jerk i'm like i was
really good at my jerk doing a short
shitty push jerk when i was younger
let's see if i dip under it how much i
can do i did 350 for six all-time pr
super proud of it i could have done 10
i stopped because my knees hurt i was
like oh [__] like what was that because
i was bound my knees shot forward and
all this stress on my knees
simultaneously sprained
both patellar tendons
i'm not kidding
what was that 2016 2016-17 uh that [__]
hurt me until about last year it was
about three or four years where going
upstairs getting out of chairs
everything hurt i got through the squat
event at a clash on it
that was the only time i've dedicated a
training cycle to using
anti-inflammatories uh every time i
squatted i had to take
800 milligrams of ibuprofen before a ton
of liniment
um dmso and then wrapped the [__] out of
my knees and it was a 600-pound squat
for reps had to suck it up
eventually the only thing that worked
because i took the advice it's like oh
well you have to keep squatting you can
modify it you can modify the work you
have to keep doing something you have to
keep lifting stop stopping lifting is
just gonna make it worse eventually the
only thing that kicked it out was not
squatting for
like 12 weeks
that was eventually the only thing where
i was walking around one day i was still
deadlifting i was still loading i'm
still doing all kinds of things
but
i remember walking around one day and
i'm like i hadn't squatted since like
march
my knees feel good
i can like kind of jog right now i can
go upstairs like holy hell and then i
started easing back into it things got
better the things that seem to make you
feel good in the short term we have a
[__] squat set up at our gym
that pins your knees in so you squat
back and it puts all the pressure on
your knees
that felt amazing so you do want to find
things that put stress on the patellar
tendon but not so much
that it creates that inflammation cycle
it's a pain in the ass man
don't do things that hurt it try to keep
the inflammation down for as long as you
can don't be
become dependent on anti-inflammatories
and don't think it's just going to get
better without being proactive that's
really what it is
uh how can somebody be lean not soft and
be strong at the same time
either have really good genetics or you
diet your ass off everybody can
everybody can it's just if you're not
predisposed to it it just takes more
work
so
you know don't get on that it's not fair
train
understand that everybody's on the hook
for working past their deficiencies
there's no amount of shitty genetics you
can have practically speaking
that will prohibit you from getting lean
and strong provided you diet right it's
your job to find where that is and if
you're willing to do it i'm not i'm soft
i've dieted very well i've got my waist
down to a pretty good position
i think i have like two pictures of me
ever with a six-pack and as fun as it
was that's not how i live my life i'm
fat right now you know you don't see me
from the chest up because i'm i'm tubby
um so it's about learning
what you're willing to do and if you
decide you're willing to do it
learn stick to it commit to it i work
from home talking to sheather that
really uh drove that point home he's
like i work from home there's no point
or there's a reason for me not to eat
the way i'm supposed to eat and i'm like
dude yeah me too
as i was eating like
trail mix with reese's pieces in it
just run small off permanently
he'll keep your gains until it
eventually kills you
uh i've been putting off my next round
of interviews freaky d you're next
in the off season would you recommend
pressing
progressing all this concurrently
or peaking different lists on different
weeks oh no no not by different weeks
no that's pointless the return you're
gonna get that's an extra level of
complexity the return you're getting
against non-existent when you peak for a
meet you have to peak them all on the
same day anyways so no i wouldn't
recommend that
as a natty what combination of trendy
ball tests and hch do i need to do
before i can grow while cutting on your
programs i can't see my app beings which
is very important to me
that's in response to my forum post
where i was tired of people asking how
to cut on my high volume strength
specific programs and i told them that
there are places that concern themselves
with whether or not you can see your
dick root and this wasn't it and i don't
know that that sat well with everybody
uh i don't know my experience trend by
itself does it pretty well trend shreds
you up uh you'll have violent
ideation you'll have nightmares
of
murdering people who slighted you in
seventh grade
but you know it'll lean you out pretty
well which is nice it's only a little
neurotoxic only a little bit
have you ever used a buffalo bar to
bench to build power off the chest no
but i've tried doing deficits before and
i find that they were kind of pointless
for me i mean i do have kind of stockier
limbs so i didn't find that to be
i don't know i was probably more worried
about going past my uh active range of
motion because i really have to stretch
to try to get down and i think that was
causing issues so i'm not gonna say it
wasn't effective i didn't do it long
enough but i did try doing deficits
using like fat grips
um
trying to think if i did something else
now i've never used a buffalo bar though
i'd be very careful using that stuff i
think it can work very well but if your
shoulders are predisposed to anything i
think deficit benching is a good way to
put an exclamation point on that
um there's no reason why it wouldn't
work the same way other deficit type
movements work just
be mindful of what you can tolerate
i'm just getting into straight training
i'm
strength training
were you doing by training before what
would you suggest for a general weekly
training plan
uh if you're just getting into it keep
it simple if you don't have access to a
coach um
and you're you're climbing the learning
curve
simple linear progression grayskull lp
is one of my favorites i like the amraps
i think that's more appropriate
um i think it's more i think it's faster
i would say
i think it's good if it's good for
novices to learn how to grind using
heavy ass fives i don't see why it
wouldn't be also good for them to know
how to grind in higher rep ranges it's
good for capacity and conditioning you
can see how you're getting better so i'm
a big fan of the gray skull p but
there's a lot of i mean five through
one's popular
they all work um i probably wouldn't
have you do something linearly
periodized like juggernaut anything that
has lp in the title is gonna be a good
approach
um better combo for bringing up bench
dips and seated overhead press those are
both fantastic most benchers have [__]
shoulders and will get very very strong
if they just got their shoulders
shoulders right if you don't press heavy
heavy ass front raises if you don't like
overhead pressing or if you're one of
those guys that you know can't press
without the bar going out a 45 degree
angle
heavy ass barbell front raises i was
doing them for bag tossing
i tossed i'd do a mini band around the
middle of the bar so that it would get
real tight right here and i'd stand on
the ends of the bands
man you go heavy go eight sixes
put some pop into it
those front delts man they're gonna be
benching some weight
i've trained for five years for
increasing my squat i've only ever back
squatted two to three times a week i've
stalled out this year at 210 kilos
let's see that is 464 freedom units is
this minimalism killing me here
um
no
most people you don't need to do
much else for squatting than squatting
the same might not be true for
deadlifting
certainly isn't true for upper body for
benching where there's a lot of relevant
small muscle groups that are required
but not built by benching squatting and
it's gonna change for person to person
not gonna you know cast a white net here
squatting benefits from squatting
big muscle groups being used full range
of motion they're stretched out at the
weakest mechanical point all of these
things are signs of a good developmental
tool
the patterning the coordination tower
designed to squat biomechanically
friendly it's a big stress but it's also
very easy to recover from squatting is a
magic exercise
now
you can
you can uh try to incorporate other
movements to add variety
start small don't go crazy if you've
never back or front squatted front
squats are great try incorporating paw
squats you don't need to go off the
rails there's a couple small tweaks go a
long way
but
even if you're on a squad only program
programming requires maneuvering given
whatever it is that your programming is
is oriented around so squat specificity
is it there's maneuvering you can do you
have to figure out what it is you have
to control for volume and effort
some weeks you're going to go really
hard effort you have to know when to
back off some weeks you're going to do a
lot of sets
you have to know when to change that
ferris i keep tweaking my leg adductors
while doing front squats you have any
recommendations for strengthening
rehabbing them beyond the good girl bad
girl machine uh yeah pinch planks are
great i had a hip imbalance after i
broke my leg i came back got really
strong debilitating hip pain for years i
don't know if it was the root of it or
if it was uh
just a concurrent symptom or what
but i had somebody do a screening on me
and they had me lay on the ground and
push out with my knee to push out like
that and i push the guy across the floor
because my glutes are really strong
dead lifting squatting strong man you
know i got some cakes
went in the other way to push it against
his hand he's like are you pushing he
said the difference was like 10 to 1.
my adductors were very weak which
probably caused some problems pinch
planks you do a side plank elbow on the
ground
top leg up on a bench bottom leg
pinching the bottom of the bench in a
perfect line
uh starting out i couldn't do like eight
seconds and then i could got up to 20
and i think the most ever did was like
30 or 40 seconds aim for a minute
um it's painful it's humbling it's a
very good exercise
do you have any progression schemes you
think are underrated and the underrated
overrated exercise big up from sweden
not really
just picking something and doing it i
think is overrated or is underrated
just uh just starting something and
moving forward making small tweaks as
you go i think that's underrated
because there isn't anything you're
missing out on that implies that there's
something you're missing out on there
isn't there really isn't there's so many
different ways of training that are all
productive you just have to figure out
what it is um
exercises any gimmicky [__] you see pop
up that isn't used by the best in the
world
that that qualifies i just talked about
z presses i don't get their point i've
never known anybody to get really good
utilizing that it's named after his
adrenals so dronus has never done a
z-press in his life
but yeah i'm sure
scrolling through my ig feed i could
come up with some but
um the main movements haven't changed
the good developmental exercises
have not changed in 50 plus [__]
years
uh
proposed rep scheme for power cleans for
volume peak training
um
that's a hard one depends why you're
doing it if you're doing it just for fun
versus if you're doing it as an olympic
lifter versus if you're doing it as a
supplementary movement for like strong
man that's hard to say i mean power
cleans as a general rule you keep the
reps low because it's explosive i've
done them for high reps because it's
strong man i mean i've had to do nine
axle cleans in a minute not power clean
but still an explosive clean movement so
strapping in and doing a [__] ton of
cleans in a short period of time is a
good conditioning tool it depends on
your goals that's too hard to answer to
sorry too hard a question answer
too open-ended
um
and your training ultimately isn't
probably going to live or die with it so
if you're an athlete
keep it explosive keep it under three
reps
if you're doing it for conditioning then
you can you can justify doing whatever
if you do crossfade you justify doing 30
reps
why do i hate on deadlifting in shorts
can't handle the calves
what's up joel
uh that is joel i believe koala 3d yep
uh i get on get on him and i just got on
uh ben kissinger is one of my strong man
clients and he did a 13-inch uh axle uh
i think it was an axle deadlift 13-inch
deadlift in [__] short shorts with
his re-band his goddamn blue rebound
shorts poking through i hate him they've
been a thing since i started in 2005.
guys as a ritual the fattest sloppiest
guy takes his shirt off and goes out to
stone load in nothing but blue reband
shorts it's disgusting the tacky sticks
to it it doesn't help you it's like
warmth do people have problems with
their hips being warm because warm means
you get like ball sweat and you get this
soup ruins disgusting everybody stinks
anyways he's doing this deadlift
and what happens the second over your
knee the second bar is over your knee
you're trying to pull it back and slide
it to lock out you can't [__] do it
because it's stuck to your gross sticky
oily thighs like think of taking like a
fat baby seal blubber
and like rubbing it with like some type
of spray adhesive that's what trying to
deadlift on bare thighs is like and
everybody does it because they want to
show off their sexy or not so sexy legs
and i hate it i get so much [__] because
i deadlift in sweats it can be 90
degrees
i'm pulling in a hot expo hall with no
air conditioning with hot ass sweats my
first show in san antonio we did pillars
of strength out here they had an expo
200 people in a building at a water ski
resort well not a resort it was off the
freeway but
200 people in a building it was like
this little fitness expo no ac
the ski lodge or the water ski resort in
new braunfels decided that they didn't
want to waste the electricity so they
shut the ac off so middle of july we're
doing the strongman show
and we're boiling we're just dripping
sweat it's disgusting and i'm out there
like something to prove i'm like i'm
moving out here i'm not gonna be the
[__] from california they couldn't hang
i'm like this is normal i gotta get used
to it
afterwards i heard from everybody
they're like no we had people almost
passing out like that was not normal
that's not how that was supposed to go
anyways i was out there you better
believe i had
long ass basketball shorts on i thought
my balls were going to disintegrate from
the heat but
once the bar gets over my knees i can
slide it back it just grabs it's like
silk it just grabs and slides right up
zero friction and it's way better than
having to dump goddamn baby powder on
your legs and make a mess and everybody
looks at you like you're the [__]
they got baby powder on the bar so
long story short
don't dead lift on bare thighs every
time you see a sumo guy doing that ugly
like
seizure hump where they're trying to get
their hips through on the bar
eighty percent of it is because the
bar's sticking on their fat [__] legs
so wear your shorts when you deadlift
can you elaborate a little bit on dup in
a video you said it's not as good as
training in blocks of distinct
thresholds but why is that um
i'd have to watch that video i try not
to make really absolute statements like
that because it's all context plenty of
people have used up
uh dup successfully
um
if i'm biased against it i believe i
said that in the past i'll own it it's
not as good
generally it's not as good because
people try to do everything at once
because they think is better and it's
like jack of all trades master of none
that's kind of
that's kind of the idea
so
i think it's best for the psychology of
the average lifter who's training
themselves
to prove that they can get good at
something
and just one thing prove that you can
organize training to get better at this
one threshold before you start
incorporating all of these other things
yeah there's studies that show that dup
is better over like six weeks just like
every other study that gets referenced i
think it's meaningless i think it's
garbage you adapt based on what you got
used to before so if you're not used to
doing all these different thresholds in
one week that's a new stimulus so you
get better
you know more people involved in the
study are not going to be used to dup
then we'll be used to it so that makes
perfect sense um the question is does
that work long term
what does it look like when you've
adapted to it
how many different points do you have to
focus on for these different days are
you going like heavy light medium or
it's like volume recovery day intensity
day are you working different rep ranges
how do you change those rep ranges how
do you adjust for effort on those
different days there's a lot that goes
into it
uh i mean you could even do like to mike
to shear does like type of dup but it's
like the same threshold but it's like
different exercises
i don't know it can get convoluted
that's not say it can't work but
it seems useless to make it that
complicated when it's not obvious that
it's better and i say it's not obvious
that it's better because
most of the good guys don't do it and
haven't and the ups been around for a
long time it's had plenty of time just
like west side it has had plenty of time
for all the top lifters to recognize
that oh this is the best way to do it
and they have it so that's why i
hate on that
jonathan hernandez message retracted ooh
what did you say jonathan was it spicy
i'm a middle-aged accountant aaron
then
boy do i have some information for you
do i watch anime
personally it motivates me for my power
building goals
you know what i don't
i don't but when i was a teenager
i'm not kidding i would say up into
junior college i did binge
dragon ball z
specifically for pre-workout motivation
100 i don't watch
current anime i was never a big anime
fan but i absolutely
did some goku power-ups in the mirror
before going into squat i
nothing wrong with that half the [__] on
my shelf is like graphic novels and
comic books like
i i stopped trying to pretend that
that's not a thing
uh
have i ever had a hip impingement i
don't think so i've had hip pain but it
was like greater trochanteric pain it's
very non-specific to this day i don't
know what it is it flares up every now
and then but it's kind of manageable
uh how to stop butt wink in a squat
uh i have a video on that go look it's
uh it's bracing it's squat posture so
just google anything with or sorry just
a youtube search anything with my name
squat and bracing and it's it's
squeezing your glutes to bring your hips
under and bringing your ribs down to
keep your abs tight so finding that
brace at the top and then keeping it on
the way down if you're not used to it it
feels very counterintuitive but uh just
spend some time focusing on it
even a little bit of bubbling's not that
big of a deal i would just say it's a
big deal if it's bothering you like if
you have low back pain that's being
uh bothered by the the tilting of your
hips
lifts are progressing but i feel
exhausted
he likes rock climbing badminton cycling
okay you like having an active life
nothing wrong with that currently doing
hlm should i do upper lower split for
more recovery yeah if you're very active
and you're doing
three compound lifts three times a week
it's hard to fit in a lot of athletic
[__] that's why you don't see these
types of programs in a lot of athletic
um
also because they're oriented towards
grinding out those five more pounds so
you're in the weeds more often so yeah i
would look towards something that has
less frequency and
is not oriented around constantly doing
the heaviest lift of your life
i think they're very useful programs for
periods of time but i wouldn't live or
die by them there's a point where i
wouldn't want to go through
endless fives and the same three lifts
over and over and over grinding grinding
grinding there's times where you just
stop feeling good it's like why
all right i'm gonna start cherry picking
um
i got about five more minutes i'll try
to get two or three quick ones in if
anybody has a pressing question
super chats go to the front of the line
um
[Music]
sean cook
your band
just stopped by to give his
body weight
experience and lifts that nobody asked
for
uh i remember when i was excited to tell
people my lifts um
you want to tell people your lifts get a
youtube platform they have to listen to
you
how did i end up in redlands i grew up
there and don't miss it at all i can't
believe there's a legit strong man gym
there love the channel by the way
i've moved all over i lived all over the
country
my dad was crazy he moved us to
tennessee in west virginia and illinois
spent a couple years in charleston
illinois in the corn fields uh went to
high school in poway in san diego
it's where blink 182 is from by the way
and then when i was right out of high
school my parents split my mom moved to
san bernardino so i moved up there
that's where her parents were from
redlands is like
the only kind of nice area in the inland
empire uh every neighborhood around is
synonymous with shitty so redlands has a
nice downtown it's it was somewhat clean
homeless were flooding in and they're
putting a a train stop there last i
checked so i'm waiting for it to go the
way of every other city in california
but yucaipa sucks
sorry to anybody who lives in these
areas but you know what i'm talking
about don't act like you don't know what
i'm talking about
highland sucks rialto sucks fontana
sucks colton sucks they're i mean
they're fine but they have a lot of
rough
they're rough areas
and that's pretty much every
neighborhood
um along the way with
you know some few residential
neighborhoods that aren't that bad
all the way out towards the coast so
anyways redlands is where everybody went
to drink
that's where the nicer apartments were
um that's where the really bougie houses
are like way in the back like they're
trying to they're trying to get closer
and closer to the hills to stay away
from the riff raff um
i don't know downtown redlands is cool
but as a town there's nothing special
about it i mean i worked at rialto for a
couple years uh next to eisenhower was
one of the worst neighborhoods in
california delivering pizzas i was an 18
year old white kid had no idea what i
was getting into um
that was an experience redlands is not
worse than realto
um
anyways me and my wife just left because
of housing prices we both make good
money doing what we do
and uh she she was a supervisor of
social work for uh riverside county
you know she dealt specifically with
everything from elder abuse to the
homeless
she made good money we simply could not
afford a house
her sister just had to get a house her
her sister and her wife
are moving in
with my mother-in-law with their mom
well with her mom it's not both their
moms
and they could not afford with her
pension and with their income they
couldn't afford to get a house they had
to pull money from everyone in the
family for a down payment
it was
a two-story house like 650 000
in beaumont
i lived in beaumont too it's okay
it's not worth 650 for a two-bedroom is
ridiculous that's why we that's why we
left otherwise we would still probably
be there
[Music]
anyways that's not where you go for
strongman i mean uh andrew mock is still
there holding it down uh and they run a
crew but like east west out towards the
coast i mean it's an hour drive
that's where di marinus and
casey garrison and leifa angles came
from scott brengel runs it that's where
i started um odd haugen has a spot out
in ventura
um
nadia trains with finnerty at a big
speed and strength of fontana so there
there's a lot of good spots around there
bar path moving forward during squats
any other tips
depends on how you're built that's a
hard one to answer without video
what's my opinion on alpha destiny's
concurrent training philosophy so that
was interesting talking to him in faz
they both use it
and at first i was like okay guys like
like there's nobody left really doing
concurrent so i came in skeptical with
my same bitter bias towards anything
that is remotely west side related and
uh i talked to them and their tweaks
answer every problem i ever had with
concurrent style training
basically it's
it's like a linear backbone
with
a concurrent
uh add-on almost it's like this plug-in
they put on top
so
they don't lean on the speed work which
is a big point of contention i had they
emphasize
um
consistency of movements
they emphasize recovery they emphasize
what they need to do to make it work for
them and it seems like it doesn't hinge
so uh alpha destiny i think uses a lot
more rotation faz was saying
uh he uses the
variations to create this thread of
consistency which i think is really
important so i i like it i'm
experimenting with something similar
myself i tried something in the past
where
i had my main lift for my main volume
progression and i use a secondary lift
to go to a max
usually something top end and just
because that wasn't as important as a
secondary movement but to see if i could
use that
as a threat of neurological stimulation
and movement selection wasn't so
important that was my thinking anyways
and i did it for a few weeks i had okay
results i didn't stick with it but
i'm experimenting with it a little bit
right now i will
i will keep you all posted when i have
uh something more
substantive
i got one more i got one more
let's see what it's gonna be this is the
last one my wife's about to kill me
she's off today we're supposed to go to
the movies
i'm like no
my fans
my followers they need attention i
committed
not backing out
what is the last one god i just used the
word fans
shoot me in the head
if you ever hear me refer to you guys as
fans
just
just end it
opinion on front squats is a hypertrophy
exercise for quad upper back
thumbs up it's a great exercise the fact
that you're staying upright forces it
does exactly what a high bar squad does
it just forces you to stay in that
position it doesn't allow you to shift
the
load back into your hips so it's just a
way of
think of it as a way of executing a high
bar with a technical
kind of choke point like if you
create this technical
no-no then you just dump the bar forward
so yeah it forces the knees forward
puts a lot of strain on the knee puts a
lot of strain on the quads so it's great
for growing quads it also does a bunch
of other stuff like really really well
including upper back and mid section
if you are a strong squatter and you
haven't found squatted the first time
you do it abs upper back you're gonna be
sore as [__] for days absolutely
so um
yeah it's a great exercise i
force i love when people put when i'm
screening them for coaching
i love when they um
talk about how they've never done them
they hate it or they have some problem
because i immediately make them do it
and i i take away the excuses i'm like i
don't care if it's with an empty bar you
will put a bar in front of you and you
will do 10 reps i don't care what it
looks like i don't care how you feel and
eventually everybody ends up working up
to substantial weight and eventually
everybody's better for you so it's just
one of those things you have to suck it
up but it is such a valuable movement i
almost have people do it
mostly continuously with the exception
of contest peak it's one of the first
things you drop because it's
not specific and it's lighter
so as you get closer to contest a the
movement variations get heavier so you
buy us towards
a pause squad or a box even a box squat
slightly above parallel i like those a
lot anyways
that is that is it for today guys
i had a flood of questions each one of
these probably merited their own video
but
you know i'm uh
it's what i'm here for i'm to try and
make this a regular thing on wednesdays
so wednesday's about 11 o'clock i'll put
it up the day before so you guys can be
ready for it thank you so much for all
of the participation i appreciate
everybody's support i'm going to get
back the interviews are fun and i got
more interviews coming down the pike but
um
i'm gonna get back to making some good
quality videos
um i'm also done
well not done but they're not gonna be
so much so many of the shortcut videos i
tried really hard to repurpose content
so i could get things on multiple
platforms um
you guys do not like the podcast clips
which is fine i i don't really like them
either i just thought that'd be a good
way to repurpose content but i'm gonna
go back to making some
some hearty videos that take some time
and attention and address content that
the way you guys want the interviews
will still be up the interview clips
will still be up
and the full interviews are going to be
on patreon and
available for youtube members as well so
if you want to get the full clips i had
a lot of people asking me about the
alpha destiny clip um i put probably 70
60 of the interview up but the full one
is on patreon thanks so much guys uh
i'll see you next time
you